we're live streaming now so the minute
we'll start the meeting was scheduled
foreign
okay everybody it's three o'clock uh
Welcome to the
September infrastructure meeting
I have one apology for lateness that is
Grant demity
um can I have someone move that move
Darren seconded Barry put that all as a
flavor
um there are no other apologies
excuse me Mr chair um I will have to dip
out at 5 30 this evening
that's fine hopefully we we've got most
of it done yeah
right it takes us to the no public forum
like it takes us to the minutes of the
infrastructure meeting from the 1st of
August can I have someone move that
they're true and correct Place who Trish
seconded Peter
we'll have some favor
it takes us to Temporary road closure uh
Russell do you want to come and speak to
that or
does it need to speaking to it's pretty
self-explained yeah I just
always like to give people the
opportunity to talk Russell
did she
this is slightly different in that the
actual period they're seeking is
actually a longer period and it's in an
area where we don't see there's going to
be any significant disruption
before that period can be accommodated
by a network so we reasonably happy to
to be able to support
to us have another event so we think
it's going to operate pretty
successfully okay any questions for us
or Peter yeah just you Mr chair Russell
are given that being a Saturday
are there any large events programmed
for rugby park be at the same weekend
because there's a lot of there's an
event on a rugby park for other people
that are team rugby park will fill up
these streets that are mentioned here
Council I'm not aware but that's a good
point we will check and coordinate with
them if there is because this is just
one block this is one that one section
so yeah
at this stage of it there's no Super
Rugby games playing for rugby Parker
weekend over further north but
thank you all we will check
no other questions okay there's three
recommendations can I have someone move
those please move Darren second Leslie
put those all those in favor
takes us now to
erode stopping
for bigger Street
hear that
thank you Mr chair
um again the report's pretty
self-explanatory this is uh Post parcel
of road with an encroachment on it
a council
um resolved two commits the rose
stopping process we have done the public
notification process
and now uh just asking for Council to
recommend we stop the road and dispose
of the land to the encroachment area
thanks right questions for Heather
no
excellent thank you okay we've gone to
oh sorry we do have a question just
going to remove okay right the
recommendations are we received the
report
and pursuant to the sections 116 and 117
of The Works act Council authorizes the
stopping of the sub six subject portion
of the road
three Council resolves to sell a stop
Road in the adjacent property owner 33
biggest street and for the chief
executive be given delegated authority
to agreed terms and conclude the
disposal of the land by the way of sale
following stopping process so we have
Liz Lee moved Evelyn seconded put that
all those in favor
begins that is Kerry thank you
now we're keeping on stopping roads this
time at Green Point so Green Point Road
again
um Council resolved to commence the road
stopping process
we have carried out the consultation
process
we had received a submission from one of
the encroaching property owners who was
interested in poaching the purchasing
that portion of the land
we had also received some information
from
haringa and noku and I'm not sure if
I've pronounced that correctly but
um in regards to some barriers
at the other part of Green Point Road
um that's just a farmer's fence and
they're recommending that these might be
looked at in the future so no real
submissions in objection
um
and so the next step will be to to
negotiate with the adjacent landowners
is to
who would be interested in purchasing
what Parcels of land
following on from there would be a
survey and then seek the minister of
land consent
to the disposal if Council agreed to the
same so again is Michael doing the
um
dealing wheeling and dealing with you he
would yes
okay
ah right right okay
with respect to the final sale any
questions for Hitler uh yes
Pioneer
um
great I'm I'm just when I looked at the
photo and in the location given it such
a long stretch of land
and uh those interested in in the coming
off the highway part
what happens to the the back piece so
there is as you won't be any other
excess vessel so Green Point Road is a
if you look at the aerial photograph and
actually is a loop yeah and we're
proposing to just stop that South part
of that Loop so there still is access
right to the back
by the loop
yeah I see where it is but I know that
it doesn't quite go right round but
would no longer become a state a loop
road yeah
yeah Barry yeah I'll just uh I noticed
on the aerial photo here on the on the
actual stating of uh
uh the bluff highway so that's got a
tiara
to a ripper is it if we change the name
of that highway or is it just put there
just for your air sake
I can't understand it I'm sorry to add a
toad I put as part of the to other or
Trail it is the part that goes from what
will play to multiple Hui oh on the
um on the side on the side yeah yeah
sorry yes so it runs down there so
that's the track Tom
yeah
um what happens if one or more
landowners decide notes take up the
offer
uh we don't want a parcel of
um landlocked land
so uh
if that is the case then we would bring
the speak to council for a decision as
to how that might affect so as a
essentially all all in a non-in is that
how it works uh it's not not necessarily
it could be
um
adjoining landowners might buy more than
the piece of land right beside their
property
further questions
no that's the case
[Music]
um
we have to receive the report review the
submissions
following public consultation
improved negotiation with adjacent
landowners
subject to the the acts as previous
116-117
we can authorize the stopping of that
subject portion of the road and again
five is that achieving executive will be
given the delegated authority to agree
to the terms
[Music]
put those all those in favor hence
Kerry thank you all right thank you
right draft government policy statement
on land transport
the GPS
not a global positional satellite
and
so the draft government policy statement
has been released by the Ministry of
Transport and um
this sets the The Minister's
expectations for the land transport
delivery into the next three years but
looking forward into a 10-year program
and the minister has set out that his
expectations are that the delivery of
the GPS be brought profound you for
money that Investments are efficient and
effective and that we build back better
and investing in maintenance and
ensuring that renewals are fit for
purpose moving into the future
um there's two new strategic priorities
that have been added into the the
initial for and that's to integrate
Freight Systems so that's looking into
well-designed operated and efficient and
resilient Freight Systems going
inter-regionally specifically
and then that there's a sustainable
Regional and Urban Development and so
that's within cities that there's um
transport options and enabling
enabling housing Supply measures and
resilient productive towns and
through the GPS they send out set out
the activity classes for hotahi and the
ranges that are enabled through the GPS
and there is one significant change in
there that there's a new activity called
inter-regional public transport which
may be of benefit to the region but not
necessarily specifically to the city
um
that's probably the main changes set out
in the Jeep this GPS 24 from 2021
I think Dad Russell do you want to talk
about our submission Mr
we would like to um change the
recommendation slightly to actually give
you delegated authority to actually
approve the submission if that's that's
appropriate the submissions I think
close on the 15th and unfortunately we
won't necessarily have time to submit
them to council but really it's the um
you'll have seen in the draft that
there's a range of questions and really
it's a response that we would like to
draft for the chair to be able to
approve which really does I guess
supports what Leslie was saying but it's
really making sure that the amount of
money that's available to us is
available is actually fit for purpose
for our roads and we get enough
maintenance obviously safety is
important but it's actually how we
actually I guess support those
priorities in the GPS
write questions anyone
Barry then Tom yeah I uh was having a
look at it and it all seems to end up
about uh s Burton there's no there's
nothing said about the bluff highway or
it's shocking that it's something some
work needs done on that
we need we need to mention that in a
submission if we're going to part of our
response that we will give to a chair
is that um we would like that the
um Strategic investment program
considers
all
um cities cities and towns especially
those that have one route in and one
route out for consideration through
resilience projects
um and that it's not just refined to
those that um
are listed in their in their program
okay
Tom
look I was going to make pretty much
exactly the same point and I'm going to
read the the draft submission that we
have here
it seeming me to be a bit light on
um
expression maybe disappointment
to have nothing south of Ashburn that
seems ridiculous to me to be honest I
mean I I I I cannot rank the priorities
I just suppose well you probably can we
cannot but I I think if there was if the
map was the other way around and there
was nothing north of Napier
then there would be outcry probably so
maybe we've been a bit understanding
Leslie
I was going to comment on that
number two in the draft submission where
you have noted the access to the buff
Township is by the one route only which
we know just interested how many other
towns are in that position
within our region there are none but I
can't comment nationally sorry
refer to the to the Rarity of that
situation just to slightly beef up the
sentence see I think it's also quite
unique in that it's actually serviced by
the state highway so I think that's part
of a one of our key strategic routes up
and down the country and
I think that's probably one of the big
differences that most townships on the
coastal are often served by more than
one or have an alternative link and I
guess that's part of I guess one of part
of our uniqueness is that we're actually
at the end of the end of the road
um and how we actually service that and
how we support that we understand our
colleagues from
wakatai are actually working pretty hard
also to actually encourage that level of
investment to make sure that roads are
as resilient as it can be and I guess
the level of detail from the GPS is
often very very high so you won't always
see some of that detail that could well
be in some of those programs but
um Council making their point that it's
actually a key route for part of our
community is pretty vital to us
Russell's just extended
brief up that reference because I I
think the the Rarity of that situation
because it just could be highlighted
even more strongly than what we've got
here now because I I actually
struggle to think of another Township
that is in that position with the state
highway
yeah
so I take it Russell that State Highway
one uh it's not equal everywhere you go
the treatment given to it so obviously
you know it's very important
um the state highway from invercargill
to Bluff is a Lifeline piece of
infrastructure so there's something
that's State Highway One it would have a
different level of um priority yeah
that's what I thought
um certainly there are different
Regional priorities for the highways and
certainly
um some of the highways like between
Auckland and Tauranga and those sort of
places have different I guess
um
statuses across the their
maintenance and operations but
we are a regional we are a regional
state highway
okay just
um
me well yeah thank you Mr chair I just
wanted to add that um having gone
through that and the information that we
received it was discipline to say that
of the 14 key projects that none of
those had been identified by Dan Hill
and other in Southland so I think that
adds further weight to the bluff route
how are these only
um one way in and out and the other
thing when I look at the costing
increases associated with the GPS plan
it equates to one dollar per average of
each motorist
and I think that
if they're serious about this draft
plane there needs to be more investment
in one dollar per average motorists on
the roads
um I've got a question oh sorry Grant
will you go okay my question was around
the extra two cents on you know leader
of petrol now
that's all fine but what about electric
vehicles are they is anyone
are they addressing that so the current
EVS are are excluded from rock until the
end of March 2024 and heavy vehicles
EB vehicles are excluded from rock until
the end of December 2025 and they there
has been recent reported
by The Herald that then the
environmental regulation project is
including investigation into E-Rock
charges but that's all that's been
um indicated from wakakotahi so far
[Music]
okay Grant then
Mr Man yeah thanks chant um just with
respect to the table on 33 of board box
in the forecast that they're making
around local road maintenance there's
the percentage increases that they are
forecasting align with the percentage
increases we have within aeroding
budgets for those same periods
I haven't necessarily done the direct
[Music]
um
the direct analysis against that
um the indications are that the
bids for the maintenance
are currently quite high so um
and those tables are a range of numbers
where they would look to see I guess
overall I've got so much money and
they've given ranges for each of those
activity classes and they will then
distribute that money where they see
bids from the councils but typically the
the maintenance and renewals bucket is
is normally oversubscribed by all
councils
um
struggle in that area so um
I would think hours
our bid isn't as high as some councils
but the councils have had some quite
significant requests for money
for maintenance requests for maintenance
renewal some councils have got some very
high numbers but I guess you can imagine
some of those requests from the east
coast of the north islands will be quite
significant so yeah but there's some
Mainland there's capital
yeah
we when when we talk about local road
maintenance that includes um our
day-to-day maintenance and operation and
our renewals so our resealing programs
yeah but the East Coast stuff is not is
a one-off capital being brought should
be
anyway
what I'm interested in is that you would
think logically that you know if we're
forecasting a five percent increase in
air routing maintenance year on year
which would be driven by cost like zero
because we're not building any more
roads per se then that should naturally
flow through to what the national budget
is but if there's a misalignment
you know
we're gonna under delivery routing
Network and our writing Network
forecasts should be put together on the
base of what air depreciation rate look
it's quite a well forecasted model
yes
so you see the issue
okay thank you uh Evelyn and then
uh yes thank you Mr chair
at the risk of being paying for
repetition
um
the importance of the lifeline but also
the economic importance of the road from
invercargill to Bluff cannot be
understated and I really really think
along with some of my colleagues that
this particular thing is a little bit
vanilla in terms of how urgent I think
this is because if we're looking even
just at climate resilience for the
people who live and Bluff
and the importance that in the event of
an emergency people can get to hospital
things like that or the fire service can
can come to the aid or something that
happens in the port but it's also the
industry that depends on going in and
out of the port and I I fail to see why
it doesn't rank
important enough to even be on the list
because this is a road that is regularly
covered by sea water not just
occasionally and
we know that this is only going to get
worse how I know that City can't do
anything about it see advocate for it
but we need to say something a little
bit stronger than what is in here I
really apologize to you both because
it's not you personally but this is so
important that I don't think
um that people doing paper exercises in
Wellington necessarily recognize
that it's a multi-pronged
weakness
that the one road
that goes in and out of our only port or
any significant Port can actually be
taken out by the Sea just whenever the
sea feels like it and what does that do
for the people who live there it's not
just to see I mean we've
just in the recently right I think it
was twice yeah I think we've got the
fact that we will
um beef the language as well and Mr G we
could also seek represented from katahi
to come and speak to council and I guess
that would be another good opportunity
to perhaps
in fact I grabbed his contact details at
the recent conference so yeah
we can do that awesome
um
just on the issue of the impact of the
ear vehicles um
with the coming election Nationals being
clear they will scrap excise tax on fuel
and have a road to Road user charge
across all vehicles depending on the
class of the vehicle so it's more evenly
spread and I think Waka Kota he's been
making
overtime to the government recent times
and especially around local government
New Zealand around their inability to
have enough funding so I think either
way whichever parties and will get some
movement on there okay right I think
we're about
all good okay we've got three
recommendations we received the report
on the government GPS we actually
received the table draft feedback for
submission and we approve
the table trap hold on we receive it uh
approve it subject to
um
straightening of Words which which
you'll ever see yeah yeah we need to
include
yeah straight things
yeah we'll just do a tweet that
foreign
okay
I'm opportunity
right totally up
okay there we have number three so can I
have someone move those
please
moved rear seconded Evelyn put that all
as in favor
against that is Carrie thank you
that now takes us to the
adoption of the CCTV policy consultation
is that Rhiannon or Andrew
counselor so um
if have in front of you a copy of the
City Block West consultation or just
draw your attention to page 10 in that
document which covers
how we would propose Consulting on a
CCTV policy
um so before I hand to Hannah who's just
going to talk you through the main
points of the CCTV I'll just set out a
little bit of context so obviously the
council has chosen to invest in enhanced
security within the city center and
we've been working for a number of
months now on this policy in order to
enable that project to proceed on
schedule
um and so we're bringing this to you now
um
Andrew is going to speak briefly to the
aspects relating to the Privacy Act
um and the aspects relating to making
sure we are meeting our privacy
obligations under a more complex
arrangement in terms of shared data
which may be likely to eventuate under
the new project but it's important
obviously just to stress that this
policy will cover both our existing
cameras and the proposed new cameras
foreign good afternoon councilors
um so I just want to reiterate what um
Rhiannon has said
um and really make you all aware that
this policy is intended to cover our
existing cameras of which we have around
200 in the city already
um as well as the expanded CCTV Network
um the work that we did in order to
develop this policy identified a need
for a standalone comprehensive CCTV
policy
um to cover those existing cameras as
well as our new ones and this is
particularly to cover our privacy
obligations
um we have managed so far with the
privacy policy as it stands which has
several points relating to CCTV but the
level of detail in the draft CCTV policy
um we suggest we'll make it much easier
to demonstrate our ongoing compliance
with our privacy obligations
um in addition the policy was developed
with the new CCTV project in mind
um at this stage we are hoping very
hopeful that the new cameras will offer
significant benefits in terms of
enhanced features and functionality
compared to the system that we have in
place at the moment
um which is good news for security but
in turn makes it all the more necessary
to have robust procedures in place
around our privacy obligations and this
policy it is intended will help us turn
our minds to those issues when the new
system is being put in place
um in terms of the consultation at this
stage we don't anticipate that there
will be any major technical changes to
the policy as we move into the next
stage of the project
um the only changes that may happen as
we get further down the line could be
for instance how we store our data which
precise systems are used but the more
significant provisions and and the ones
that are um really gone over in this
policy things like who has access to the
data
and in what circumstances people can
access data those things will remain the
same so we don't anticipate at this
stage any need for further consultation
beyond what we're currently proposing as
part of the city block west consultation
okay right so we're gonna open up the
questions both both on the uh policy for
the CCTV and also anything to do with
privacy as well right same with Tom
uh I'm I'm always a little bit concerned
about the privacy in these situations
and it's well dealt with in this paper
but you know the thing that did catch my
eye
on page 141 on board books it talks
about CCTV footage will continue to be
stored securely by Council
as is currently the case
and then I think it's in page 147
it says
147 it says it'll be stored securely
um for no longer than is necessary to
achieve its purpose which implies it can
be forever
and you know that's assuming maybe a
little bit unusual uh I would have
thought that there would have been a
time limit on storage or part of
anything else it requires a lot of files
if you're going to store all that
information forever right so I I mean I
don't know what would be reasonable
three years five years or something but
I just don't think it should be quite as
open-ended as
as is it expressed in the policy
thanks and that in minutes of our
question as part of the issue that we're
grappling with and I suppose that's the
key Point remember that this is really
at the moment particularly addressing
our current circumstance where we have a
few cameras but we don't create a lot of
data we don't keep it for very long
obviously as we add more cameras add
more detail on those cameras the storage
and all those issues will need to be
addressed as part of that and then we'll
have to make some hard decisions around
what is the appropriate time to keep
them how much money do we want to invest
in storage and all those things will
come back through at the moment there's
a bit of flexibility because
it's it's aimed to provide guidance for
those two scenarios but the actual
process and what we actually do when we
get those decisions made we'll we'll be
much more precise and we'll have that
guidance in there but we'll come back
once we know what that looks like to be
honest
right just oh is that that answer or
sorry
um from a from a technical point of view
um
I imagine the the system would rewrite
itself it has fixed the amount of
terabyte and once it depending on how
much terabyte you want would give you so
many months back and then it rewrites
itself if you want to store information
you would need to actually identify what
you want
and then you would put that particular
file but it wouldn't be you're not
storing
you know Limitless amounts of nothing
forever no it would be right so if you
want to speak so you could ask a
supplementary question I mean it it
means there for the
decision on how long we store stuff is
it would be fundamentally a technical
decision a technology decision rather
than something which I'm talking about
which is more linked to privacy policy
um
and you know I don't know other people's
views but it just seems to me that
um you know that we should have the
element contained and it might be that
from a technology I think you Michael
would like to answer through self-cheer
Look in relation to the um Privacy Act
um there is certain times when you will
be obligated to um hold
um certain information for an indefinite
time frame
um that could be in relation to whether
there's some um act that has been
um
filmed through those particular cameras
that require us so we might be imposed
to actually keep those images for a time
frame that we we are not able to Define
in relation to that which leaves us the
ability through this policy to comply
with those obligations and that could be
through the crime scene for example
there and and we also got to remember
that some of these things not so much
purely for this but for instance these
live streams are also subject to our
attention requirements under the
document storage as a local government
ND as well so there's a whole range of
requirements of about how long we keep
documents for and what sort of documents
are and when we can get rid of them that
we'll have to make sure we comply with
so that's why it's got some flexibility
to try and take into account all those
issues but one of the drivers will be a
pure technical one how much can we
afford to store
so what what happens if there's a
technology limit
Which is less than infinite which is you
know the situation where there are
particular events that we have to store
that that the determination of that is a
combination of uh the quality of the
image so whatever we choose how many
megapixels we choose for cameras
and then we also look at obviously the
quantity of cameras and then you look at
how many terabyte you need to achieve
one month two months four months
six months we would the the uh the
people putting the system in would come
to ask
ask how how much do you
roughly want as a safety net
realizing that in between if you realize
something in Queen's Park is or an e
Street's damage you can go straight in
and grab that and store it on a USB
device or something but as far as just
randomly going back that decision would
have to be made by this Council
through yourself chair um there is
archives and deep deep archives in
relation to the storage capability so
those images that I was referring to in
the first case would end up being in our
deep archives side of it
from perspective of when it becomes a
legislative compliant sadly the cost
prohibitor doesn't come into the
equation we we will be used to slate of
Lee required in some of those cases I
wouldn't have thought that would be a
cumbersome amount but we would end up
putting it in a deep archive which means
it's
doesn't take up as much storage as as
it's in a readily accessible component
but there is time so that we would need
to do that and
sadly that does mean we have to look at
our storage capability digitally does
make it a little bit easier than in the
physical form from that perspective
right okay that's Tom gas for the rest
of the day and now we move to we've got
a grant Evelyn Leslie Alex and then Nami
okay thanks to you so a couple of things
note that the lack of response from the
government around government apartments
around the Privacy thing
um if you go on to the um this web page
it clearly states that the policy for
CCTV must outline how long the
information is going to be kept for so
that's
that's to Tom's point and must be stated
as part of a CCT program
um what my question is though is there's
other cities that have this technology
use it have we reached out to them to
review their policy or we're just trying
to reinvent the wheel
the short answer is yes
um the long answer is that the devil is
not so much about
again we've got two different questions
here the first one is
um
our existing policy works for our
existing users what you're talking about
is the sharing of information and
where the devil is in the detail is that
the investigations which you all would
have seen from the Privacy commissioner
have all looked at whether the police
have dealt with the information that
they have been able to access
appropriately and they've been able to
say we got it from the council who dealt
with every privacy issue from their end
and so it's that interaction that we're
really talking about which is very gray
um in terms of what that agreement looks
like and that's why this policy says our
policy is to deal with privacy in
accordance with the Privacy Act and
pretty much when you break it down
that's what this says
we will have an arrangement with whoever
accesses our documents that ensures that
both we and they comply with the
obligations under the Privacy Act and
that's that's the bit that isn't in
there that there's no transparency over
those agreements there are councils that
have agreements with third-party
providers there's but but in but it's
core it's that individual agreement that
will drive our relationship with third
parties and that's that's the piece of
work still to be done so supplementary
so there's what cities did we speak to
because they're actually using this now
right yes so which cities do we speak to
uh I don't know in specific but we
looked at all the policies that they've
got presented on the paper on their
websites and had a review of different
policies that are around and that's why
we're into the Privacy Commission
because they've done investigations in
all these places and tell me which which
approaches you all looked at the targets
that you've got compliance and that's
why we went up to that level to try and
say and that's where we got to the point
where they said well we don't have any
more we haven't looked any further at
that these issue other than what's on
our website so we haven't spoken to any
particular people on councils or have
just ridden their policy statements
we've looked at their policy statements
and we've spoke to the provider that
we're looking at for who we were going
to provide it to and ask them for their
documentation around what they're going
to give us in terms of what that
agreement will say and how we'll be able
to ensure compliance and it all turns on
look and the problem we have at the
moment is that we've got an existing
a lot of cameras that we use and we
think
there hasn't been any issues we managed
them okay the policy covers that the
problem is once we start to share with
the third party that is a it is a an
individual transaction we've got to deal
with that as it comes up and see what
that looks like see what the usage is to
see whether or not they're going to be
storing it see all those things will
have to be dealt with for one of a
better description on the Fly this
policy just says we will do those
conversations consistent with this
policy
happy ground
I'm so happy okay Evelyn
okay so the first thing I don't want to
get too much in the mud about the
operational side of the those particular
things but I imagine that where the
Crimes Act applies is going to be where
this the long-term storage is going to
be really important because you've got
to cover the person's right to appeal
and all those sorts of things I imagine
that they're going to
want to be able to access it for a
a longer number of years rather than a
longer number of months all right
yes but in the short answer in this has
been touched on to a certain extent most
of the time you'll know that fairly
quickly and so there'll be copies that
won't necessarily be on us the police or
whoever will have a copy and so there'll
be other versions around we won't be the
sole repository it really comes down to
a fundamental question how long do you
think is an appropriate time for someone
to come back to you and ask a question
around a crime that they might have not
not have otherwise asked you that's
really what you've got to ask yourself
because once it's identified
effectively what um the CE and the chair
were saying you'll pull that out you'll
store it somewhere else someone else
will have it you can then
the original can be disposed of in a
different way
it's to make the policy or to make the
cameras effective it's no good keeping
them for two hours might be no good
keeping them for a week you might say A
month's an appropriate time and that's
what will drive your decision making but
you'll make that decision once you start
to say what are we using it for what's
our purpose
a lot of hypotheticals that will have to
be worked through to make
the approach and everything you're doing
practical and functional from a cost and
a user perspective
so my my principal question apart from
that so thank you for that reassurance
because I thought that that was what I
backed up but the the systems that don't
talk to each other what are we going to
do about that because I noticed that in
the year as well that
as we're adding on this new system will
talk to all parts of it but what about
the stuff that we have existing now and
what are we going to have to do to make
it a more integrated
um package and
is that something for
two years down the road or something
like that
um I think the short answer is is yes
that is probably a conversation for a
little bit further down the road
um the the CCTV we have is is of just
mixed
um Quality and usefulness etc etc
um part of the external consultation
that's going on is um sort of
identifying the weaknesses and the
strengths in that system and um figuring
out how we make better use of it so
that's that's all part of the um sort of
the the new CCTV project as it's sort of
being called that's going to be rolled
out it's not just here's some new
cameras it's looking at the system as a
whole and making sure that everything is
working effectively
thank you Leslie
thanks Mr chair I was just going to make
the comment that on page 147 it says
but it just kept no longer than
the Nichi that's perfect
so you have to go back to page 145 and
look at the lust of purposes there
and we're not at the point yet where we
actually have worked through all the
implications of that whole set of
purposes that are on page 145 so
forwarding of the moment in this draft
that what's on page 146 is reusable
and needs some work and we'll probably
come back to this committee for more
refinement yeah either not too distant
point but I'm not sure at the moment
that we could
Define it anymore in this particular
particular draft until we've worked
through all those purposes and their
implications for instance
the purpose statement includes
obligations under legislation saves the
Privacy we know the crimes it and I can
think of several other X that actually
would have created obligations so
there's quite a bit more work to be done
absolutely and I totally agreed there
um Alex I'm thank you Mr chair I just
wanted to
um discuss and perhaps outline that um
in the end of the updated privacy policy
it's got a bit about accessing and
correcting your personal information and
a bit about what we're obligated to do
in terms of notifying breaches to the
ACT but it doesn't say I say or outline
the process on how anybody could
actually notify of a subscribed or
obvious breach so if anybody is a member
of a public and they think that their
data is being used for a particular
purpose or they've witnessed somebody's
data being used for a particular purpose
or being accessed in any manner
um can we just clearly outline what that
process is for the reporting
no way
not real but um
um on one of the early stages of page
six or the reporter talked about um
public consultation between 8 September
and 10 November uh but what we don't
have in any of these reports any
indication of the time frame when we
start installing them and I'll see you
smoking and and when some of these stage
effects will actually be completed and I
get a lot of inquiries from the CBD in
particular saying hey we've got
Christmas holidays coming they are
higher risk areas when kids are out of
school
and unsavory Behavior going on when will
you have your cameras in place I can't
answer that so that would be helpful if
we could have that going forward it's
interesting that we talk about
um storage but it seems as though we're
a little bit light on how we how we
share particular information so when
it's requested so as an example
um how easily would the police get
access to an information if there was an
incident in town or do they have to put
in a request form and wait for somebody
in Council to come Galloping in and open
up the system and then share the
information so that's the first issue
the other issue is it talks at length
about on one of the sections about how
we um
um how we have certain requirements to
not use it for anything that's not an
hour and our Focus I guess is counter
that was on page seven of eight
um and it says that um
uh the purpose of council is what we
should be clicking for
um and that leaves us a little bit
um Shackled but um that we that we as a
council don't have an obligation for
um
resolving but of course the other way
around there is to just entering
Community safety and the well-being of
the community if you put them in it's
one of your guidelines then you've got
any amount of authorization to start
start watching what's going on in your
community
um
so be helpful to know how quickly the
piece can get access to that
um
and it's always been my obligation and
when we've done this sort of stuff in
the government sector it's better to err
on the side of retaining something
you're not sure about
because you can always be directed to
deleted but if you do it the other way
around you get rid of it then you've got
no ability to recover
and the other issue that Michael was
returning about is we can't take
information off the system of source
store it separately but what guidelines
do we have when we share that
information with a third party
what guidelines do they have to hold on
to the information which is still ours
so good example is please come along and
it's been a stabbing in the car won't
get well I've got too long ago and
somebody dies they see that the video on
that or the data that comes off the
system well statutory limits for murder
are open-ended so you can allow murder
charge 50 years later if you want to so
does that mean they retain the
information while they go through that
period And so some of those things
are different to the standards that we
might have in place
so while this is a really good document
I still think there are gaps that we
should work our way through
because we will have criticism that big
brother is watching everybody that
that's what will come to us when we
install a whole lot of these cameras
and I think most people in the community
would like to have one because it makes
them feel safe
but there are still those that have the
conspiracy theory that when I am of some
organization that's trying to watch
every every bit
and so um
the document talks about us and
potentially the police but there are
other vestive parties so for argument's
sake Emergency Management Southland
might want to tap into our camera system
at very short notice to see where floods
are going or not going
um
would it extend as far as a alcohol
licensing facilities that we authorize
if we had evidence of people staggering
out absolutely legless would that be
data that we could use from our cameras
to question their suitability to be a
license holder I mean this gets quite
wide as you expand it out so
just a whole lot of questions I'm not
looking for answers today just
thank you Nami uh rear then grab uh
thank you Mr chair so I just wanted to
reiterate what Lizzie has brought up
earlier
um about the stage of where this
document is at and also there may as
well there doesn't need to be some Gap
colors here
um my concern is that cuts across this
policy will cut across between four five
six even seven different sets of
legislation so for me it's really
important that this policy fits within
those guidelines and absolutely meets it
so that there are no unintended
consequences on any of the organizations
Community people accessing that data or
actually members of our public one of
the questions I was interested in too
was obviously the places are going to
have access to some material and however
they submit that request is I guess in
the the writing that's set for them but
this like knobby you just said about a
murder act or something like that so the
place where access to have access to a
crime from our data you know and then
what about the third party does the
media get
um to print though there's images in the
newspaper and then the information then
carries on to a court and some kind of
criminal
um element so I'm thinking in my head
we were talking about third parties
accessing that data
um it also has to fit within all of that
legislation that this policy will cut
through
um so that's probably where my concerns
are in what Alex said accessing and
collecting your personal information
um I'm interested I know this is can be
worked on later too if someone rings and
says I'm sorry but you don't have the
right information that you're carrying
for me and that person's a set inside of
a um crying situation when they require
for court and their information is not
right and if the chemist catches
something that is
um
can be proven to be not quite correct at
what stage could that information be
corrected because it says here
um that it is up to the council to
correct that information if they feel
that information is right so what would
that process be like Alex said to ensure
that the information is correct as soon
as possible
so that's probably where my concerns are
coming from
I think I mean just a
it
many of the questions and the
differences between policy and procedure
the policies by its very nature abroad
and as I said you could really just say
comply the Privacy Act the privacy act
itself actually prescribes many of those
procedures for us and so we could relay
them all out in here but it just becomes
but we need to have and we do have dogs
we can see behind it so we already have
people who correct their information and
we have a process we go through for that
this is really just to highlight the
specific issues that will come around
with CCTV and also to highlight some of
the issues that will come around when we
go discussing those exact points how do
people get access but until we have that
proposal that we can work through with
this policy and create the procedure
we're just shooting a little bit in the
dark we're saying yes third parties will
be able to access who they are we'll
have a different procedure for each one
press as a general rule we would say
didn't would not have a purpose for it
and so we wouldn't release it but until
we know the scenarios we're looking at
we then revert back to policy and say
what does the policy say what does the
Privacy Act say what's the purpose of
the access why have we got the
information and it's back to the mayor's
first point and it's it is drawn out in
here because it is fundamental the
Privacy Act starts from the proposition
that you cannot collect information that
you do not need great
so from the go to Woe that's got to be
the first question we ask ourselves why
do we need the information because it's
true of any information
CCTV by its very nature is very Broad
and makes that question more difficult
to answer
because do we really need to know a
whole heap of stuff that a camera will
capture and becomes even more
complicated if you start looking at the
quality of the camera the detail you can
pick up whether or not you go to any
sort of audio not that I'm suggesting
we're doing that but all those layers of
complexity we will have to work through
once we know what the proposal finally
looks like
different subject right okay last one is
Grant and then we'll
I'll trade off my question to Tom
no
no Tom's gone
um just um it's a little bit thanks to
you just
um two things in one to The Miz Point
around is this project on target
so I'm not sure if that's a question for
you as chair of infrastructure or it's
the Council of surfer is the lead on the
project but are we on target we promised
the community where Deliver Us in
February 24
are we on target with this project well
look I've got some I got some timelines
here and the first one is the network
okay so the cameras set on the network
and that's that's critical so our
Network
without it that's a simple question no
no no no no but I'm going to give it the
timelines okay so Network implementation
first of October 20th of November that's
what our timeline is right okay and then
after that uh or concurrently with that
the you've got
um looking at
suppliers potential suppliers
uh and we're looking around city center
implementation of the first lot would be
December that's according to the to the
dates that that were sort of kicked off
for a start but Aaron do you want to
comment on if we're
if we're sort of along those lines yes
so absolutely the information you've
given is 100 correct and part of the
response that I was going to give I
think the other piece is that when we
put forward those timelines we always
said they were going to be challenging
to meet so we wouldn't give any
guarantees I think at any point through
this project that we are 100 guaranteed
to hit that Christmas deadline but at
this stage there is nothing that has
jumped up and told us that we won't meet
it so we are pushing ahead as fast as we
can I have taken on board the feedback
that was provided at the council meeting
and we will pull the project into the
project management office reporting
structure so that will come through the
formal finance and and projects
committee reporting
um and we'll continue to provide any
updates if we are aware of delays Etc on
the project
to mentioned my name is yes it is right
thank you okay so we have um Ivana I
have asked
um I've got a second question with the
subcommittee to come to the October
infrastructure meeting to do the update
and that's sorry I confirmed that we
would bring that to the October
financing project okay championship
yeah well that's your committee Grant
there we go we'll be on three more
questions
um no no one more just with respect to
page three of eight and again this is
probably more for the project as opposed
to yourself but
if I'm reading that correctly we've
identified some areas around the broader
CBD
um where
um initial locations for the cameras
it's on page 308
who's decided that
look I wouldn't jump in or I'm speaking
of the cafe but uh I wouldn't jump in
and assume those locations are correct
it's all dependent on the network and I
don't think Aaron is that true we
haven't that really hasn't been done in
in the final Detail no absolutely not so
those are initial feedback that we've
received around locations that we have
been asked to look at and prioritize
um as councilor pottinger says that will
be Network dependent but it'll also be
budget dependent in terms of how many
cameras we can afford within the budget
and where we get best impact from having
those located yeah so that's from the
stakeholder group you've received so so
the key thing to realize with the camera
even though it may have a position
marked on a map
depending on what its lens is yeah yeah
so and and and everything like that it's
the image is really what we're after and
so the committee it'd be nice to know
what we're going to be looking at what
are the views not so much where the
cameras are
it's what what the final picture
well equally it meets the needs of the
stakeholders right yeah absolutely okay
radio we've got
um four recommendations here
we received
the report
um agreed to consult with the community
on the draft CCTV policy
a doctoral consultation the draft CCTV
policy
and note the draft updated privacy
you know if someone moved that please
moved rear seconded Peter I'll put that
all in some favor
against that is carried no takes us to
the last item which is in public which
is the
activities report
okay and do you want to speak to that
Aaron or absolutely
um
so I'll take the majority of the
reporters read the key piece I'd just
like to highlight attention to is that
you may have noticed that at the end of
the report this time we've included a an
update around the three Waters pipe
renewals program there's obviously been
some commentary around elected members
interested in some of the other programs
of work apart from the Strategic
projects that are currently underway
so we've included this one I guess as an
example of another program of work that
is likely to be a more high profile one
in terms of its impact on on the roading
Network around the city
um you'll see there that it provides and
I do apologize we'll have a little bit
of a look as to why the clarity hasn't
come out as great as we would like on
board books but you can see a list of
the various different projects down the
side divided into whether they're a
storm water pipe FAO sewer or water pipe
renewal project and also there what what
phase they are in whether they're in a
planning design construction or closeout
phase of the project
and in terms of I guess understanding
where the project will be what what at
what time the project will be impacting
the community you can see the the blue
there indicates the construct when that
project will be in construction phase
they're happy to take any feedback on
that Edition or any other questions from
the report questions Grant yeah um
thanks Chad thanks Aaron I think that's
a really good oversight and a good
addition to sort of
so you get one thing I would raise just
in the comments there the trouble you're
having getting a response from kiwi roll
is that something the man needs to get
involved in I mean that's obviously
significantly impacting that project
in you know what I've heard through
other things I am with the bluff
Community he'll slow there to respond
and we'd probably need to wake that up a
little bit in my view
um look I think we'll just start doing
it this week we've somewhat done that
through this process in terms of the
team we're struggling to get that
engagement that was required
um we went and did some research around
getting some uh names a little bit
higher up the chain that we went and
poached it still took a little bit of
time but I think it was an interesting
process for them because we actually
kept um everybody as we were sort of
pointed from person to person we kept
the original people on the chain and
they were actually able to see how
inefficient it was with it as being
actually given the run around across
multiple people
um and that's actually what got us some
good Traction in the end when they I
think realized internally that the
process was a bit broken so at this
stage we're hoping that that's been a
little bit of a wake-up call but if we
can't continue to find that we're not
getting better traction absolutely we
can escalate that and I think it's just
a reflection of the beauty of the report
we can see us count to what problems
you're having so that's a good second
question if I may um just with regards
to the new writing contract transition
um you're working with the stakeholders
to work together and understand the
delivery expectations we will see that
back through this committee
that hadn't been the intention at this
stage essentially when we're speaking
around that we've got a
um there's been a number of meetings
through the transition and then we've
got the first kickoff meeting for the
governance group for the contract
um on on Friday next week uh Friday this
week sorry
um
at this stage probably we weren't
planning to bring that back to council
but it's something we can have a little
bit of a think about around giving some
visibility of those key priorities of
the of the new contract yeah well two
things once it's a significant contract
but equally in the community has a
significant impact around Service
delivery so my sense is we should have
some level of over sort of that you know
just for
keeping in touch with it as opposed to
anything else but happy to be
the other voices Ellen
um yeah I've just noticed on um page um
five or seven that you you mentioned all
the things that have been you know done
in July in the snapshot thing I'm just
wondering I've got a question about um
Road verges besides of uh rubbish on the
road verges
is there any program for for cleaning
those up because as you drive around
certainly in odatara in the sort of
semi-rural areas I guess you know it
does seem to be a problem and road
sweeping isn't something that's going to
fix it so just wondering is there any
any plan is there any person that does
their job I've seen community members
doing it in fact
um this it's a it depends in terms of
whether or not it comes into the scope
of this contract or whether or not it's
picked up as part of our parks around
whether or not it's Road Reserve or
whether or not it's a garden or park and
Reserve but I guess um it's absolutely
not lost on us that there's an issue
there and we're not doing well enough
um it's one of the things the key
priorities that I've actually fed into
this new contract is around actually
wanting us to look like a city that has
pride in its appearance and that we're
not really at the Mark that we want to
be at the moment and that does go down
to both that rubbish in the gardens as
well as sort of glass in the urban
Channel things like that so absolutely
it'll be a focus of this contract going
forward and I know it's also been a
focus area for the parks team as well
yeah I'm talking about like Karen's Road
you know umatara Road Bluff Road in fact
yeah uh not
roadside usually pick up litter
collection in those more sort of on
those more rural roads it's more CBD
based um but something that we can have
a look at as well
okay Grant again yeah thanks cheer
um taking over Tom's Mentor is the
number of questions
um I think Alan Ray is a really good
point and
a concern I would have is if we take
responsibility picking that rubbish up
versus if we engage our community about
taking care of their own little village
or part of their Village or park and I'd
really like to see us maybe do some
initiatives you know locks with Queens
Park where we have
um you know take care of the park there
it could be Thompson's Bush or it could
be seaward Bush where you know we turn
up we might put on some coffee carts and
a sausage or something and we as a
community take care of it they have
areas and just get a sense of Pride back
as opposed to council just put more
services on which cost us money and deal
with the problem that you know in an
ideal ideal Society shouldn't be this
just a thought I think it's a good point
yellow roses
right uh Evelyn so partly in response to
Council of Germany
um self alive has initiated debt in
South City for for quite some years
um and
I think it's we could all do it yeah
that's wrong you know instead of it's
somebody's job it's actually our job
um but communities
um could be engaged more than they are I
it's not for me to say how a community
particular Community should respond but
if you see the need then perhaps you
need to be talking to neighbors or
whatever and say can we just do this one
one day every three months or something
like that however the thing I wanted to
raise was it's just a notion here note
number our recommendation number three
notes the potential increase in housing
care applications due to changes with
Presbyterian Support Services rental
units it's just there there is nothing
to follow that up now I know that it's
an issue
um
not lost on me that that report has been
out there in the community but in terms
of the people who are going to be
displaced some of whom might be
prospective candidates for our housing
because they're already in
um
foreign
you know supported housing community
housing what however you want to phrase
it
do they get priority for any vacancies
in our system or do they have to start
at the bottom because this is actually
quite urgent and what
if anything can City do to help this
particular crisis situation
I think there might be a separate
discussion we are noting there's a
potential increase so that would which
committee would that come to
yeah as part of elderly housing in terms
of the the note the note refers to a
comment in the housing report around the
fact that we haven't seen as yet an
uptick in uh applications
um despite being aware of that change at
Peacehaven but it's something that we're
keeping a watching brief on
um the team have also been out and have
had discussions with the um Peacehaven
residents
um but you're you're right there isn't a
different pathway into the process
um and I I think I'd warrant caution
that um
all parties who are currently on the the
waiting list are obviously parties with
need otherwise they they wouldn't be on
the waiting list and so I think I'd urge
caution in considering a fast track
approach
where are we in increasing obviously
we've talked about a lot where are we an
increasing the number of units from
where we are now that is that is one of
our projects isn't it the minute yeah
thank you um yeah that's one of the
projects I'm working on at the moment
with uh
with a couple of councils but it's not a
short-term fix I mean I'm I'm picking
it's probably a 12 month plus type thing
we need some assistance from government
we need to free up land and we need to
get some income from that land to be
able to do some of the stuff okay yep
there's no there's no quick fix no
thanks all right sorry trash I'll just
read in addition to what Grant said I
think we probably could encourage
service clubs to be part of that they're
always looking for projects to do I
don't know how we do that but you know
perhaps the cons team was something good
ask if they were interested
right okay we have four recommendations
there for the activities report
you can either someone move those please
move Barry seconded Grant we'll put that
all those in favor
those against
that is Carrie thank you that's all we
have for the public section
um I like to move now to the public
excluded section and then doing that
acknowledge that I move that we allow
Rob Scott and Keith about who are doing
the update on wastenet to us a verbal
update be allowed to join us so can I
have someone second there please thanks
Barry I'll put that all those in favor
aye thank you
and